and that's really why i'm really upset
about this scott
is um the unnecessary
nature of screwing you it's one thing to
screw andreessen horowitz
the founder of quora my friend roger
dickey from gigster
and other folks who are already affluent
and have had their payday
but i'm assuming you haven't had your
payday that's why you're working still
you haven't had your big payday and you
know what you took a chat with this
company
you took that and you hit the 10 chance
and then this
and i'll say it you don't have to this
and i'm saying that to tasa right now
you are for doing this to this employee
this is so horrible that you
i wish nothing
but horror for you in your future i hope
you get sued by these investors i hope
you are pariah i hope every employee
leaves your company
and i hope that the employees leave your
company
tasso i hope your employees leave the
company and
raise a round of funding and do a
revenge startup and i will be the first
to give them a million dollars if they
do it i am
infuriated now tell me
scott about your company no and i'm
i i'm sorry if i was out of line there
scott but you have to forgive me because
i hope they start a startup i win
exactly
but i mean i i am so on fire about this
because
as an angel investor myself if
the people who worked at uber or com or
robin hood were screwed the way you were
screwed
the entire framework of silicon valley
falls apart
you have talented people who are taking
less money to go to these startups
and if somebody like this piece of
garbage tosso
duvall garbage where to do this on some
regular basis
the entire system collapses and you know
what just because you can do something
legal
tasso duval just because you can legally
be such a horrible human being
how did your parents raise you tasso
seriously how do you sleep at night
this man should have made his 10 million
he should have made his nut he did the
work for you
give him his money
i'm pissed off throw that man i'm sorry